بين مؤيد ومعارض ينقسم الشارع الاسرائيلي
بعد اعلان رئيس الوزراء المكلف بنيامين
نتنياهو عن تشكيل حكومه جديده مع شركائه
من الاحزاب الدينيه واليمنيه المتشدده
عصريه ولا اعتقد ان ستستمر لاكثر من عام
واتمنى ان لا تستمر
نامر ان تكون هذه الحكومه حكومه يمنيه
حقيقيه اعتقد ان هذا تفعل كثيرا من الخير
لشعب اسرائيل ولبناء الدوله وبناء مستوطنه
جديده
نفسي
المعارضه الاسرائيليه من جهتها اعربت عن
غلقها من ضم اليمين المتطرف الى الحكومه
خاصه وان العديد من الوزراء هم شخصيات
مثيره للجدل على راسها
زعيموا يهوديه القوه اليهوديه ايتامار بن
غفير الذي عين وزيرا للامن القومي كان قد
اذن بالتحريض على العنصريه ودعم منظمه
ارهابيه
ضد الفلسطينيين حصل على حقيبه الماليه الى
جانب حقائب اخرى
والممثل الوحيد لحزب نوع من المعروف
بمواقفه القوميه ومعاداته للمثليين في
معوز حصل على حقيبه التعليم
تاتي هذه تشكيله جديده بعد ان حقق تحالف
نتنياهو اليمني فوزا مريحا في الانتخابات
التي جرت في الاول من نوفمبر الماضي وهي 5
في اسرائيل في اقل من اربع سنوات